well I'm going to show you is the small
detail of the hands will determine what
the technique becomes
the techniques are already performed by
them attacking you but somewhere within
all the movement and their attack
there's lots of different places where
you can defend yourself by doing
different techniques
and that's what we're looking at we're
looking at sometimes Palm down up
sometimes Palm down sometimes middle
position
so there's three places you know while
doing a technique you can get techniques
one
two my palm is down I have to twist it
halfway
I can do two genagi what we call cross
arm so
Georgina
one
my palm is going to go all the way up
and I'm going to take shinagi
foreign
because it just happened to be there
all right
that's funny can't escape the attorney
only you can only do if you've got big
hands so therefore you use your
you have to understand all these
they will be in there they'll be
available to you these are our senses
movements
one
I want to put this hand in his hand but
I've got to go and get out the way for
my own safety
both hands are down
that run even if it hurts my wrist
because of the hairs or the skin I've
got to turn it Palm up and push that one
down
I now have both hands one Palm down
front Parma
I now can do the shiny
only experience that people can take new
camera from it so don't do the ukami
this is
huge and Aggie
[Applause]
all in there it depends what time are we
stretch the curtains through the
techniques
once more slowly
one
two I've got to turn the bottom one all
the way
three
we're in the cross one you can't see the
shooting so at least you see it's become
natural
something's coming out of uh just
movement
cross arm
y
what you're doing is you're trying to
work out how you get this bit now you're
you're thinking this way all you have to
do is change direction
foreign
[Music]
one
you go that way it's your Negi
you turn direction
okay
so
change direction
you just change direction the cross arm
one
same direction
there's always lots of techniques and
you don't worry if they attack you wrong
there shouldn't be a systematic
process it should be it's there
cute
but when you're learning and you have to
go sorry you have to do A123 method
I'm gonna face the camera
and then you can do this